after disney fired james gunn as the
director of guardians of the galaxy vol
3 in july 2018
the three equal film meant to close out
the franchise got pushed onto rocky
ground
and placed on a temporary production
halt now reports have surfaced that
suggest guardians vol 3
might get completely booted out of its
spot on marvel's release schedule with
what's being described as a surprise mcu
film replacing it
so what is this unforeseen marvel
cinematic universe installment
according to the folks at geek the
answer is kind of strange
stop screen geek recently picked up on
an exclusive report that the daily
mirror published in mid-august
one that claimed benedict cumberbatch is
poised to earn just under 10 million
dollars to top line a sequel to his 2016
solo superhero movie doctor strange
the daily mirror further alleged that
marvel will get dr strange 2 behind
cameras in spring 2019
estimating that filming could take as
long as six months taking this nugget of
information
screen geek explored what it could mean
for the mcu as a whole
coming up with the idea that doctor
strange 2 could take precedence over
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 on
marvel's to-do list
the outlet pointed to cumberbatch's
reported 6.6 million dollar salary
increase as a primary piece of evidence
supporting that idea
and looked to a mysterious message
doctor strange director scott derrickson
posted to instagram as additional
cooperation
in july shortly after guns firing
derekson shared an image of dr strange
from the marvel comic books with the
caption
not my will but thine be done see you in
september
many fans took this to mean that marvel
had gotten to work on doctor strange too
and that the studio would be making a
major announcement regarding the sequel
pick sometime in september
it would be easy to shut down the idea
that dr strange 2 is really in the works
considering disney and marvel haven't
made an official announcement about it
or given it a release date however
marvel studios president kevin feige
did actually reveal that a doctor
strange sequel is happening
he told cinemablend earlier this year dr
strange you know whenever we do another
strange one which we will do
it will be a number of years from the
first strange and yet he's a very big
part of avengers infinity war
so it is just a good problem to have
when you have too many beloved
characters that people want to see more
of
popular speculation is that marvel will
release dr strange 2 sometime in 2020
the same year guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 was meant to debut
at least according to gun if the daily
mirror's report is to be believed a 2020
premiere for doctor strange 2 would
certainly make sense
an early 2019 filming start date and a
mid-2019 end date would
give the filmmaking team at least a year
to piece together the movie
add in what's bound to be a ton of cgi
and smooth out any kinks
the real question here though is whether
doctor strange 2 will actually replace
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 on
marvel's movie docket
marvel never formally dated guardians
vol 3 but the studio does have three
dates in 2020 reserved for mcu entries
may 1st
july 31st and november 6th the 3rd
guardians movie could have occupied any
one of those spots
and if marvel really does plan to launch
doctor strange that year
the sorcerer's sequel may have knocked
guardians 3 out of one of those dates
unfortunately it's all a big bundle of
conjecture for now but with derekson
teasing what could be a huge
announcement in september
it appears that things are really
heating up for the dr strange sequel
for the time being however marvel fans
can still look forward to catching
captain
marvel avengers 4 and spider-man far
from home in 2019